Randall good morning your reaction to
Tiger Woods well I was disappointed I
think like the rest of the golf world I
was excited at the idea that Tiger Woods
would come back he's already given us
two of the greatest comebacks in the
history of this game in 2008 when in the
US Open and that's the various injuries
in scandal coming back to number one in
the world 2013 I thought what can he do
next and the idea that he could come
back and maybe give us a back-and-forth
with Phil Mickelson was was enough to to
celebrate but we're pushing that
champagne to the back of the fridge it's
going to take a few more months for him
to figure all this out what do you make
of the statement in the word vulnerable
I think that's an athlete being very
particular about his word choice not
trying to define himself you know what
he has around the Greens there's no
other way to talk about it except to
call it the yips you know this is more
commonly seen in baseball and even in
baseball they don't use that term
they'll say an athlete or a baseball
player has a misplaced focus or they're
playing with a deficiency or they
they're being a liability the very
careful not to define an athlete as
having the yips and Tiger Woods I'm sure
is well aware of all the problems that
he has around the greens but to sort of
augment them by labeling them the yips I
think would even exacerbate the problem
so vulnerability to me means subject to
attack and anybody that's ever had the
yips are seen them knows that they come
out of nowhere and they just attack
golfer is he being smart well I don't is
he being smart yeah I think he's
reluctant to come out on on wherever
he's at it's the biggest stage in golf
maybe the sports world that weekend and
he would be reluctant to come out and
put on stage something that is so in
contrast to what we're used to seeing
from Tiger Woods so yeah he's protecting
the legacy in the image of Tiger Woods
and rightly so yeah that's what I'd said
before that he's protecting a brand here
that you don't want to show you've been
vulnerable you haven't played well but
you still have a brand to protect and
the amount of money that he makes
through nike and his other endorsements
here but
it is it would you rather have an injury
or would you rather have something
that's psychological Oh an injury by
high a wide margin you know you can
injuries heal a psychological problem
and that's you know their varying
discuss scientific discoveries on this
is it mental is a neurological muscular
whatever it is it's going to take some
time for him to get over and and to your
idea about protecting a brand imagine I
mean imagine if Michael Jordan came back
and played at the Wizards but couldn't
make a free throw imagine a far played
for the Jets and the vikings and he
would throw it into the stands on a
quick out that would be a lasting legacy
of those tremendous athletes and and i'm
sure that's in the back of Tiger Woods
mine he doesn't want to have the last
piece of video to book into his career
one would be the 12 shot victory at
Augusta National and then it's the
display of all the yips and the blades
and the chunks so yeah I think you're
right i think he is protecting a brand
what do you think the writer cup did for
him i think it made him envious probably
you know watching the open championship
Phil Mickelson henrik stenson go back
and forth I'm sure it was frustrating
for him to sit there and watch these
great golfers who he knows when he's at
his best they can't hold a candle him
and I'm sure he was watching the Ryder
Cup watching you know the great play by
Phil Mickelson and thanking at my best I
can beat this guy um easily uh and and
he's making 10 birdies and getting all
the limelight and I am so much better
than these players at my best I want to
get out there and play but then you know
I'm sure reality slapped him in the face
and the issue of the yips you know it
just it just doesn't go away it's it's
so sad to see but imagine enduring it
how do you get the ypsi again there's
studies on this going back years decades
you know Mayo Clinic has done two big
studies on this books have been written
about it this guy dr. Richard Crowley
has written a book
can baseball called the mental game and
he has his players you know the steve
blass t sack shawn green all these guys
Knobloch that got the yips and baseball
and he put them through mental exercises
and supposedly he got them to the other
side of it came back to its former
teacher yes I can hold on for a second
Brando your phone's breaking up what see
if we can get him back where's going at
the yips it have you ever had that then
when you playing casual golf or do you
not play in a competitive enough love I
don't think I was good enough to get I
think you have to be at a certain level
to get the yips I wasn't good enough to
get the yips I do think that the more an
athlete thinks the worst they are and
I'll go back to the comment that John
McEnroe made to me years ago I said what
do you think when you play and he goes I
don't think I react when you think then
it kind of yet there's a hesitation like
I'm thinking about something instead of
just doing something yes he is there a
difference between the yips and then
having say a tick or something that
you've developed like Sergio Garcia had
a pre-shot routine where it took him
forever and I think it got into his head
and then it felt like it went longer and
longer and longer but I think I think a
pre-shot routine or a tick is going to
be different than a Yip but let's ask
Brandel Chamblee rejoins us as you were
talking about the the yips in how you
get them yeah well as I was saying Hank
Haney his former teacher said he's seen
11 year olds who've never even played
the game who had this malady he's worked
with surgeons who were fine in the
operating room can do any surgery and
can't come out and make a foot putt
another another fella by the name
Richard Robert Pritchard wrote a book a
study about the stronger the grip the
more the tighter you hold onto the golf
club and he stated or used his example
players like Ben Hogan Tom Watson Johnny
Miller that over hundreds thousands tens
of thousands of shots that it tears the
muscle fibers and causes scar tissue and
when the tension of the arms causes
muscle spasms everybody chimes in on
and Richard Crowley the doctor wrote the
book mental game says it doesn't matter
how you get them it doesn't matter what
causes them nobody is ever gonna know
nobody's ever going to land right on it
they're not going to get their arms
around it the only thing to do is to try
to figure out how to solve the problem
in golf the only people that have solved
the putting yep successfully are people
who completely change their method or
came about it through a mental sort of
in a more cognitive way like Tom Watson
but around the Greens you see Vijay
Singh he didn't have the chipping hips
but he was having problems chipping he
went to cross-handed for Tiger Woods to
get over this I think he's going to have
to go to a completely different method
maybe cross-handed or start to chip like
a Jim Furyk where you get really upright
and you completely eliminate the wrist
hinge going back and through some
completely different method where he no
longer uses the leading edge and he's
able to get around play around this
deficiency before I let you go the odds
for Tiger to win a major next year are
twelve to one would you take those odds
Wow I think it'd be better hundred
dollars on that you're gonna lose a
hundred dollars yeah you're gonna lose
110 I'm sorry yeah yes news I stand
corrected a hundred and ten you're
absolutely right so you're not going to
take my son I would take the odds on him
to play at a major championship you know
I would take those but but to win one
that's another story I actually didn't
think he would ever come back and play
golf so if he comes back and plays it's
a plus for the game of golf I hope I'm
wrong I hope he comes back and plays and
gets over this element cuz Golf is way
better and way more interesting we're
tiger around Thank You Brandel thank you
that's some Brandel Chamblee the Golf
Channel the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you